twitter veut-il transformer ses
utilisateurs en police de l'information
le réseau social planches à l'heure
actuelle sur bird watch une
fonctionnalité dont le but est d'aider à
la lutte contre l'effet de news et
l'idée est simple après avoir rempli un
formulaire
les utilisateurs pouvons ajouter un
tweet qu'il considère comme
problématique à une liste de
surveillance
intitulé bird wac le tweed visé sera
alors affublé d'une petite icône
laquelle permettra d'accéder aux
modifications apportées par les
utilisateurs du réseau twitter travaille
sur un outil de modération pour
surveiller les fausses informations sur
sa plateforme
les modérateurs peuvent signaler les
tweets voter pour déterminer s'ils sont
trompeurs et ajouter une note si les
utilisateurs peuvent déjà commenté les
tweets pour exprimer leur avis twitter
veut désormais aller plus loin l'idée
est de laisser à sa communauté la
possibilité d'émettre une opinion sur la
véracité ou la qualité informative des
tweets mis en cause twitter n'en est pas
à sa première tentative visant à
différencier un bond d'un mauvais de
suite
début août le réseau social avait décidé
d'affubler les comptes de plusieurs
médias du libellé affiliés à un état et
de réduire la portée de leur publication
contrairement aux médias indépendants
les médias liés à un état utilise
fréquemment leur couverture de
l'actualité à des fins politiques
les gens ont le droit de savoir quand le
compte d'un média est affilié
directement ou indirectement un acteur
étatique avec néanmoins quelques
différences de traitement un exemple au
hasard le compte twitter de rt se voit
gratifiée du libellé médias affiliés à
un état russie de même que le compte de
la télévision centrale de chine la cctv
en revanche rien pour france24 médias
pourtant financée par paris idem pour la
britannique bbc
pas de libeller non plus sur le compte
twitter de national public radio
pourtant financée par washington un deux
poids deux mesures tout à fait assumée
par le réseau social lequel se réserve
le droit de désigner
média jouissant d'une indépendance
éditoriale et les autres bernoise
constitue donc une nouvelle étape dans
le contrôle des contenus voulue par le
réseau social
si l'idée peut sembler séduisante pour
lutter contre les fuites mensonges et
insultant violences xénophobes ou
sexistes cette nouvelle fonctionnalité
peut aussi constituer un formidable
outil pour des groupes très bien
organisée souhaitant faire taire ou
discréditer leurs contradicteurs c'est
ce qui se passe ailleurs actuellement
avec la politique de modération de la
plate forme ces dernières semaines
plusieurs comptes d'utilisateurs
influent militant journalistes et même
syndicats ont été suspendus pour des
motifs très floue voire assez
contestable mon compte twitter a été
suspendu plusieurs heures expérience
inédite pour moi mes réflexions
twitter est maître chez lui c'est donc
son droit embêtant tout de même de ne
pas recevoir de twitter france un
courriel expliquant quel tweet à soi
disant enfreint ces règles sur son
compte le directeur général de twitter
france la sueur je désapprouve ce que
vous dites mais je me battrai à mort
pour que vous ayez le droit de le dire
reste à savoir si twitter appliquera ce
précepte à l'ensemble de ses comptes